more eggnog please we drank all the  eggnog oh we get bars I don't know are  you an insane person who thinks the only  way to get eggnog is to steal the eggs  of a mythical beast called of a nog then  you'll need the eggnog camouflaged log  disguise yourself in the eggnog  camouflaged log to slip past the  mythical nog and steal all the eggs from  its nest  well nog nests can take many forms such  as a lady's pocketbook your co-workers  office a stranger's jewelry box or a  private parking garage filled with  luxury cars  then collect all your eggs and one of  our patented egg sacs sold separately  mail them to us and we'll extract the  egg nog and ship it right back to you at  no charge and just like that you'll be  enjoying fresh holiday eggnog it's the  eggnog camouflaged log just 195 ninety  nine ninety five ninety-nine  [Music]